bonjour à
tous donc je crois que certains parmi
vous se demandent c'est qui cette
madame qu'est-ce qu'elle a fait comme
parcours quelle carrière a-t-elle fait
pour mériter d'être présente aujourd'hui
parmi tout ce beau monde et bien pour ne
rien vous cacher pour tout vous dire
sachez que tout comme vous je me pose de
même
question si je suis ici aujourd'hui
c'est suite à la demande de mes
étudiants et du directeur de l'école
monsieur qui m' qui m'ont demandé de
venir vous raconter mon histoire c'est
une histoire que j'ai raconté à mes
élèves et qui apparemment les a touché
donc je vais vous raconter cette petite
histoire j' était une
fois
moi alors toute petite déjà je jouais
comme tous les enfants mais mon jeu
favori était de jouer à
l'institutrice je prenais tous mes poupé
peluches parfois coussin tout ce qui
pouvait ressembler à des élèves je
commençais à donner mon cours jetais ma
blouse blanche la blouse blanche de ma
mère qui travaillait dans le secteur de
la santé les lunettes de mon père et je
me mettais à donner des cours j'étais un
professeur sévère je prenais mon mon
rôle très au sérieux he
jouer plus tard à l'école bon plus tard
je commencais à jouer avec les voisins
et voisines les cousins et tout mais
c'était toujours le même jeu je rentrais
avec les copi à la maison je
corrigeais à l'école
mon destin éta déjà tracé je je savais
déjà ce que je voulais faire enseigner
je suis amoureuse de ma ma
àp je sal
passage regard la vidé il sont ai sur
facebook
ber dans une école française compris cé
idoles tellement bien leur métier que je
voulais le ressembler je me suis dit un
jour je veux être comme
eux au lycée les choses se sont
confirmées j'étais dans un lycéetique
CER mais j'avais d'excellent
professeur donc surtout les professeurs
de littérature de français d'arabe de
philo donc je me suis dit bon voilà
c'est clair je veux toujours enseigner
sauf que j'avais un petit penchant vers
la langue française je voulais devenir
professeur de français c'était clair
donc j'ai abandonné les matières
scientifiques les mathématiques et je me
suis concentrée sur ce que je veux faire
donc automatiquement j'ai choisi
lailière
littéraire j'obtenais d'excellente note
une bonne moyenne qui me permettait de
de de de de passer facilement de classe
en classe jusqu'au baccalauréat où là
j'ai eu le premier accident de ma vie le
premier accident de
parcours
alors cet accident c'est la
mention j'ai eu mon bac avec
mentionis excellente note en français en
arabe et en Phil j'avais 18 en français
18 en Arab et 17 enil à l'époque 17 enil
c'était quelque chose cétait la
meilleure moyenne
régionale donc et c'était l'époque où on
a commencé à distribuer à faire la à
distribuer les feuilles roses vertes
blanches donc j'ai eu la feu rose qui me
permettait d'avoir le premier choix donc
j'ai reçu le guide et tout à coup j'ai
eu on a eu tellement de visitees à la
maison il avait les voisins la
famille tout le monde venait à la maison
pour voir ce que je pouvais faire avec
cette moyenne donc chacun se mettait à
multiplier mon score pour voir ma
moyenne une confession pour voir si je
pouvais accéder à l' chaussée à l'INSAT
l'école de médecine pourquoi pas hein
bah tuas le score tu peux le faire
mais je suis nul en mathématiqu je suis
nul dans les matières scientifiques la M
moyen que j'ai eu en mathématiqu durant
tout mon parcours secondaire c'était 5/
20 donc c'est pas possible a a ouais
c'était pas
possible donc ils son sont dit mais
quand même faire français tu peux le
faire si tu avais eu 10 11 c'est TJ mais
tu dois profiter de la mention hein tu
as une bonne moyenne tu as un excellent
score donc il faut il faut le mettre
quelque part donc ils sont se sont mis à
dénicher he le guide à le feuilleter à
fouiller laDans jusqu'à ce qu'ils ont
trouvé la perle rare c'était une école
qui leur convenait parfaitement c'était
qui existe toujours Institut Supérieur
de comptabilité et d'administration des
entreprises on va faire de la
comptabilité hein mais justement cette
école demandé 20
littéraires pour faire AES
administration économique et sociale
donc il m'ont dit voilà c'estit pour toi
c'est c'est pour les littéraires donc
certainement il y a des matière adaptée
au littéraire donc voilà c'est ça c'est
ce qu'il te faut laisse tomber le
français laisse tomber l'enseignement tu
sais ma petite he tu as eu la chance de
ta vie on va
te tu tu vas passer 4 années dans une
faculté médiocre tu auras ton capess au
bout de la deè fois on va te jeter dans
un patelin lointain et tu vas galérer et
tu finiras ta vie dans un hôpital
psychiatrique voilà
non mon
destin que mes parents et ma famille
l'ont pas alors jeavis pas encore ex je
me suis dit si mes parents me disent ça
c'est qu'ils ont peut-être raison donc
d'accord je vais faire is ma mère elle
m'a dit mais je mets français en deè
position comme second choix non non mare
dit j'ai toujours été attirée par le
métier de juge un sence juridique c'est
pas mal non plus h allez deuxème fois et
puis après tu es libre tu peux mettre ce
que tu veux donc j'ai mis français 3e
position et philo en 4 en 4e
position quelques jours après je reçois
le courer
j'ouvre je lis nous avons l'honneur de
vous informer que nous avons accepté
votre premier
choix je sais pas pourquoi j'ai pas été
contente he j'étais même déçue
je me suis dit bon c'est peut-être c'est
ça l'émotion
c'est donc je me rends le jour de
l'inscription à
l'écolee au guichet il y a une bon qui
me reçoit elle me donne le formulaire à
remplir je remplis je mets AES
elle me dit mais c'est quoi c'est vous
êtes en train
de de commettre une erreur mademoiselle
j'ai dit mais ah Mo je suisire oui mais
ça c'est l'ENF vous nêtes pas au courant
de la réforme bah à partir de cette
année il y a plus de AES c'est le Tron
commun on fait SG Scien de gestion et
c'est au bout de la deè année que tu vas
choisir ce que tu veux donc mais SG a
SG pour moi ça ça voulait absolument
rien dire j'ai mis SG hein j'ai posé un
j'ai mis le j'ai posé le formulaire je
su
rentr alors pour vous épargner les
détails j'ai passé c'est l'année
scolaire la plus cauchemaresque de ma
vie j'avais des matières
bizarres mathématique statistique
microéconomie macroéconomie d'autres que
j'ai jamais réussi à
retenir la seule matière que qui me
parlait un peu dans laquelle je
comprenais un peu ce que le professeur
racontait c'était la psychosociologie
psychologie d'entreprise des coefficient
05 donc euh je suis allé voir mon père
je lui dit écoute papa c'est pas
possible je comprends rien je comprenais
pas comment mes camarades arriv à
remplir la feuille d'examen à résoudre
des équations et moi j'étais là toute bê
devant ma feuille à regarder des
parenthèses des chiffres des COS des
signes hein des je me posais la question
existentielle mais qu'est-ce que je fais
là qu'est-ce que je fais c'est pas ma
place donc j'ai parlé avec mon père il
m'a dit écoute ma fille dans la vie on
fait pas ce qu'on veut dans la vie il y
a des devoirs la passion ça c'est autre
chose va perdre la peinture si tu veux
fais de la musique lis des bouquins mais
là t études c'est c'est sacréut pas mê
les choses donc tu vas continuer et je
vais voir si je peux te trouver un
professeur de
ma donc il a chercher un peu il a trouvé
un professeur suici apparment donc il
est venu à la
maison d'ailleurs il est venu une seule
fois il voulait plus revenir hein il a
compris que j'étais un cas désespéré al
il m'expliquit le sinus le cosinusand je
comprenais pas il me dit je don une
astuce tu le fais avec le dérivé au
machin mais c'est quoi les
dérivé dit écoute c'est pas possible
hein laisse tomber fait autre chose ma
fille c'est c'est pas ta place donc il
est parti il est plus revenu mon père me
dit tu t'en sors essaie de t'en sortir
c'est pas mon problème dis-moi ce que
j'ai à faire
je j'ai fa ce qui me semblait bon je
rentrais plus au cours je passé plus de
temps à la buvette d'ailleurs j'ai
appris la
botte j'ai passé plus de temps à la
buvette classe et bien l'entendu avec un
parcours pareil je pas réussir donc j'ai
redoublé et là j'ai passé les vacances
d'été les plus cauchemardisses Dee ma
vie mes parents avaient honte de moi
voulez plus me parler il étz déçu mais
déçu
humilié vouleit plus aller chez les gens
il vouleit plus recevoir les gens à la
maison parce qu'il craignaient qu'on
leur demande alors ta grande qu'est-ce
qu'elle a fait pouvait pas dire qu'elle
a
redoublé donc euh j'étais plus leur
fierté hein surtout qu'à part l'école
hein je j'écrivais un peu donc je
publiais des articles à tuniss Doo il y
avait mon père qui monrait ma fille ce
qu'elle fait ce qu'elle écrit vous avez
lu ça vous avez donc et du coup elle a
échoué elle a eu son mat avec montion et
aujourd'hui elle elle
redouble c'était ils étaient très mal et
moi aussi bien entendu je me sentais
doublement
coupable et là ils ont décidé de
d'aborder le sujet et me dire alors faut
trouver des solutions qu'est-ce qu'on va
faire
j'ai
français tu as pas fait tout ça pour
refire français mais c'est pas
normalutre chose c'est quoi cette autre
chose moi si tu fais une réorientation
c'est pour faire les sciences juridiques
moi c'est une école prestigieuse devenir
juge c'est
pas vous croyez mais on va pas donner
parce que c'est pour
les le nombre est limité et puis moi je
serai réorienté mon dossier sera examiné
en dernier lieu et peut-être que
j'auraès on va essayer déposer des
demandes des demandes B on je dit
d'accord hein dans le cas hein euh euh
dans des situations pareilles parfois on
na pas he il faut pas trop insister donc
on a été voir le chef département des
des droits à
l'époque on a déposé des demandes on a
montré on lui a montré mon dossier mes
notes on lui a expliqué qu'il y a eu un
accident qu'on n pas été bien informé
par rapport à la réforme et tout donc il
nous a dit laissez votre demande et on
va vous
contacter quelques jours après je reçois
un
courrier j lou
jeis nous avons l'honneur de vous
informer que nous avons accepté votre
joie je sais pas pourquoi je
pas mais bon les Ch s
fa je suis allée à l'école des sences
juridiques le premier jour hein déjà
j'étais installé il y avait le
professeur qui donnait son cours
magistral et les étudiants prenez des
notes prenez des notes prenez il y a des
étudiants qui viennent de la Faculté des
Sciences Juridiques
non prenez des notes prenez des notes et
à la fin j'en pouvais plus j'ai dit à la
fille à côté de moi mais il est sérieux
c'est quoi tout ça qure pages rectoverau
mais il m'a dit écoute écoute moi je
refais l'année hein panique pas hein je
je vais te donner un conseil tu vas
apprendre tout ça ce soir fa pas laisser
les choses s'accumuler hein et tu les
apprends mot à mot hein c'est le droit
on joue pas article texte de noi et tout
ça il faut c'est tout ce qu'il fallait
pas me dire moi et le parcourisme ça
fait deux je suis incapable de répéter
la même phrase une
phrase donc j'ai compris j'ai je voyais
déjà l'échec devant moi j'ai compris que
c'est raté encore ça va je vais ccher
une deuxème année l'année prochaine
serairogataire peut-être que j'arrêterai
les études je
finirai je sais pas comment je sais pas
comment je vais finir donc là je me suis
dit bon faut arrêter je vais retirer mon
inscription je vais passer une année
blanche et l'année prochaine je vais
faire ce que j'ai vraiment envie de
faire je suis allé voir mon père je dit
et papa pas possible je suis en train de
de de de commettre la même bêtice que
l'année dernière j'aime pas ces cours là
c'est pas c'est pas ce qui me convient
le
mieux je veux je veux
arrêter pas sérieuse qu'est-ce qui t'a
pris
là tu veux arrêter mais tu joues
quoi j'ai droit à des
titittit
peutêtreelle est ensorcelée on lu jé un
mauvais
sort qu'il faut aller voir marab qui lu
donne je sais pas quelle portion magique
pour qu'
revienne tellement désespér les PV chque
matin voir alors je te
conduis j'y vais
pas le lendemain
alors c'est censuré
alors je crois que tu as bien réfléchi
on y va non j'y veux pas je vais retirer
mon dossier je passer une année blanche
l'année prochaine je vais faire ce que
je veux maintenant c'est moi qui va
décider et il sort c'était comme ça donc
à la fin il a compris que c'était pas
possible le temps passé
moi je je tenais bon il m'a dit mais
qu'est-ce qui te prends qu'est-ce que tu
veux je veux faire français he la
littérature française je veux aller dans
une pque de lettrre une F qui me
convient donc là on a essayé de
rattraper le train en marche nous sommes
allé voir le chef Département des
lettres desard on a repé le dossier on
lui
expliqué chos on a supplié on a rédigé
des demandes dit bon rentrer on va vous
dire
pourpre quelques jours plus tard je
reçois
unier
j'ouvre je
lis nous avons l'honneur de vous
informer que nous avons accepté votre
joie et pouver rejoindre la Faculté des
Sciences
Humaines je suis incapable de vous
décrire ce moment ce
sentiment
voilà pour
moi la vie
commençait le bonheur commençait les
études c'était exactement ce que je je
voulais lire des bouquins lire des
bouquins c'était ça je passais des
examens sur des bouquins que j'adorais
hein Flobert standal montescueux
Voltaire donc c'est c'était la passion
j'ai passé 4 années le temps passé
tellement vite j'ai eu ma maîtrise j'ai
passé mon tapesse j'ai je l'ai eu d la
première fois contrairement à ce que mon
père me disait hein bon c'est vrai que
quelque part il a eu raison parce que on
m'a affecté à B quand j'ai eu mon C
ouais ouais je suis allée en pleurant je
dit finalement il avait raison qu'est-ce
que qu'est-ce que je fais ici c'est quoi
ce Blade on comprenait même
pas mentalité complètement différente je
voulais
aller prendre un café dans un salon de
thé du salon de thé mais tu es où là
hein faut dire que je venais de la
Grandlieu Nord he c'est pas hein je
voulais me balader un peu sur le
boulevard quel boulevard donc il y avait
rien rien
rien j'ai eu du mal enseigner le
français à B il faut le faire aussi hein
donc il y avait des élèves qui regard
qui
étaient carrément qui ne regardaient il
navait même pas le droit de regarder un
film en français un documentaire en
français donc
c'était un
défi donc je pleurais tous les soirs
mais en même temps je pouvais pas
abandonner peti petit il a une affinité
qui qui s'est construite entre moi et
mes
élèvesè il ne sont pas bê lorsquils
comprennent que vous êtes passionné vous
vous donnez à fond ils le ressentent ils
le comprennent et ils sont
reconnaissants donc au lieu de pleurer
sur mon sort et de dire qu'il a pas de
buv qu'il a pas de cinéma qu' a pas de
donc j'ai créé mes club des clubs dans
le
lycée donc il y avait un club de théâtre
un club de poésie et un club de cinéma
chaque qu on regarde un film dans le
débat pour la poésie donc je venais
écouter les poèmes de mes de mes élèves
leses de théâtre je venais regarder mais
a jouer donc la semaine était assez
animée du coup je voulais plus rentrer
ça me plaisait bien et puis j'ai eu un
certain
succès j'ai senti un peu avec un certain
pouvoir j'arrivé à changer les choses la
mentalité et tout hein parce
que une pièce de théâtre avec une fille
lui dire que je
t'aime cétaitabou c'était impensable
aujourd'hui ils le font avec une aisance
extraordinaire donc
voilà à la fin j'ai j'ai eu ma fille
hein donc je pouvais pas faire la
navette donc j'étaé permé à
Tunis je suis venue à D en pleurant je
l' quitté en pleurant aussi
c'était difficile et puis à Tunis j'ai
été affectée à laba à manoba jusqu'à ce
que j'ai atterri à
Subcom donc un beau voyage subc j'ai
essayé de de mettre ma petite touche
heureusement que j'ai eu la chance de
tomber sur des des personnes qui m'ont
fait qui m'ont fait confiance notamment
Monsieur Mohamed
donc ils m'ont demandé il ils m'ont dit
tiens fais ce que tu veux l'essentiel on
veut des résultats je crois que en
matière de communication nos élèves
aujourd'hui communiquent beaucoup mieux
nous avons une activité qui qui nous
démarque particulièrement le stage de
langue
hein les cours de technique de
communication sont assez originaux
hein
ouais tu conf hein donc on chante on
danse on fait des on fait les fous en
classe on s'amuse tout
simplement donc voilà euh mon petit
voyage donc
euh tout ce que j'ai pu retenir
euh après tout ça c'est que pour être
heureux le bonheur c'est de faire de sa
passion
son métier la seconde c'est par rapport
à
l'enseignement enseigner j'ai compris
que enseigner hein comme guérir pour les
médecin est une affaire d'affect de
plaisir et que pour réussir dans la vie
professionnelle il faut vraiment aimer
son son
métier donc avant de vous quitter je
crois que je vais répondre à la question
du départ vous voulez savoir qui je suis
et pourquoi je suis là
aujourd'hui et bien je suis une
enseignante une toute simple
enseignnante qui aime son métier qui est
vraiment passionnée et c'est justement
cette passion qui m'a donner ce
bonheur le bonheur de partager ce moment
agréable avec vous donc suivez votre
passion la passion me suivra
merci